في الثامن والعشرين من مايو سيتنافس مره
اخرى على رئاسه تركيا في جوله اعاده تحدث
للمره الاولى رجب طيب اردوغان من جانب
وكمال كلجدار اوغلو من جانب اخر وبينهما
يقف سنان اوغان فهل سيرجح كفه على اخرى
[موسيقى]
اذا قررنا ان نكون مع تحالف ما فسيتم
التوقيع على اتفاق معهم ونضع الشروط التي
تضمن عدم تقديم اي تنازلات فيما يتعلق
بالحزب الديمقراطي المؤيد للاكراد لدينا
خطوطنا الحمراء لدعم اي مرشح كمكافحه
الارهاب واعاده اللاجئين لقد تحدثنا عن
هذه الشروط من قبل
تكمن قوه كليجدار اوغلو في جوله الاعاده
بقاعدته العلمانيه القوميه الثابته ستدعمه
مهما كلف الامر افكاره اقرب لكتله سنان
اوغان الانتخابيه ويدعم التوجه نحو نظام
حكم برلماني ما يعزز حضوره بين الشباب
اردوغان من جانبه لن يخسر من قاعدته
الانتخابيه اليمينيه الدينيه المحافظه
مهمته الحسابيه اسهل يحتاج فقط الى اعشار
لتجاوز عتبه الخمسين في المئه يبقى
الاقتصاد هو مفتاح صندوق الاقتراع من يقنع
الشباب والاصوات المتردده ان مستقبل تركيا
سيكون اكثر ازدهارا سيجد سبيله نحو كرسي
الرئاسه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات